[Music]
>> Hello.
My name is Lihang Li.
I'm from Microsoft Research
Asia.
Today I will present an app to
you and the name is Intelligent
Chinese Learning.
So this app is to aim foreigners
to learn Chinese.
We know that globalization is
joining the whole world.
Communication between different
people from different countries,
speaking different languages,
with increasing diversity.
So it's very important to learn
a foreign language.
So Intelligent Chinese Learning
is a native app.
So to provide you a mobile
experience to learn Chinese at
any time, anywhere.
And it starts from the
conversation.
It will teach you the
verbage, the
vocabularies and grammar and you
can see we have a virtual
teacher here.
So you can chat with the virtual
teacher on specific scenarios
like this one.
So you can buy -- maybe you want
to buy some fruits and will give
you some keywords and other
suggestions you can repeat and
learn.
On the tech part, we've got an AI
technology, right?
So the speech recognition and
natural language processing.
So you can see this chart and
input AI Chinese language
speech, put it to phonetic and
prosodic and use some technology
to guess the similarities.
So you'll get a score, feedback,
and this way you can improve
if what you are doing is bad.
So you can see this is the video
that we recorded, and this is
the virtual teacher and this is
a screen of the app.
I think the app will do a great
job to aim foreigners to
learn Chinese.
I recommend that you can try
that out.
Thank you.